hello world welcome to this video
playing very long one has a very high
rated player set a new account and what
kind of account is that yeah what what
kind of account is that one minute 1700
15 minutes okay just one loss five
minute is very high three minute is kind
of mediocre the one minute reading
however is pretty weird so okay I'm
going to play this game I will see what
happens even though that looks like a
very fishy account let's see one two
three okay one two three
I am I know maybe just takes long time
check yeah we have a cemetery ation and
even though the account looks fishy we
cannot automatically assume that it is a
cheetah so let's play that game and see
what happens before I go I have five
there should be three is interesting
then black has some interesting options
can play 95-96 and they're both
interesting therefore may move though
yeah if five is also possible a couple
of interesting moves I think these six
is move also f5 or f6 yeah I go to six
yeah attacking the center and try to
ultimately get to the c-4 pond I have my
fair share of experience with the same
Michonne them on the black side so I on
the white side I'm sorry
yeah from the black side I also have
played it sometimes of course if you
play the new zone it happens okay what
if I take on the phone whoopsie aide
aiming towards yeah maybe the set is
okay aiming towards c-form taking first
to not have him give him an option to
take on c5 and open up the D farm c5
okay fatigue there he might ever I have
to right he might do the door to a rock
cliff - no no he doesn't
okay five I have a queen d5 it still
plays it says some kind of discovery or
I don't you okay let's see or is she
just taking no I just takes interesting
interesting yeah
maybe six pawn can be a little bit
weaker that's true that's definitely
true try to play actively here and they
take the knight it cannot move due to
keep on mate or above okay 93
theoretically speaking tf1
Wow
maybe rookie 5 yeah yeah maybe this
activating in that way it takes 90 X my
night is ready to jump to C 4 or 2 D 3 9
f form
okay
yeah okay okay now let's get that guy
gets gets banned for cheating that's
it's already pretty clear nobody plays
like that nobody plays like that so we
have a very clear cheetah here but okay
anyway they're still going to play the
game till the end
and afterwards er yeah hit hit the
complaint button so what is happening
here Knight f6 cheering it's difficult
to make a movie as b6 is also hanging 94
I probably place some had also g4
activate Roxy to look-see one yes of
course nicely calculated all that one
Jack probably his stock fish or whatever
he's using yeah care Portland's party
stuff black resigns okay here we go
message alright so on yeah that gets he
gets okay so that is that is done so I
don't forget it yeah why is there a
cheetah because first of all we had a
look at the account it looks completely
fishy yeah one minute on 1700 you want
to fool me yeah but you have a kind of
world-class five minute rating yes sure
so this is this is the first thing we
had in the game he spends already a
couple of seconds for very simple
opening moves that he just should I play
out of the memory in a way even though
it wasn't this typical five-second thing
I mean he he took a little bit longer
for some moves or whatever but what also
was pretty clear if we go back there
with the way that played out now yeah
that start with T five that is kind of
kind of still own story that was wrong
wrong buttons it's so kind of okay but
here here yeah King f1 that is already
well I mean the normal move for human
player would be just to take here or
there's not a 94 okay okay maybe King f1
is the only where didn't see 94 I was
expecting Mugen five rupee to what okay
and this
okay here at ID if I've already find
highly artificial okay
and then here Bishop b2 is this this is
K this is really cool yeah I mean this
this looks completely normal and not
even so bad for wider but no he when he
goes we should be too weird
so all this and now yeah I mean huge
trouble already I'm losing stuff engine
says this is still playable even though
white is better after Luke 21
not sure why I booked it one exactly do
you expect the check but it seems that
he doesn't have anything great him Chan
yeah endgame is lost and it is pointless
against an engine so we have one of
those cheetah games again um what what
why am I so sure it's the it's the let's
say the amount of circumstantial is this
the right word evidence yeah the the
fishy-looking account and the fishy
looking game
I was actually thinking during the game
because I didn't see night before that
King F 1 is also computer ish but very
computer is also that night I avoid be
should be too
yeah plus the fishy-looking account so
this is going to get reported and very
lucky event
okay guys still thanks for watching